es gibt neue hinweise für die existenz
von auto zum leben auf dem mars wenn
jetzt hat eine nasa forschungsteam ganz
in der nähe des mars rover curiosity
eine quelle von methan auf dem roten
planeten lokalisiert eine spektakuläre
premiere kommen wir so endlich dem
außerirdischen leber auf die spur klick
substanzen future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den granat und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst der kids los geht's
herzlich willkommen jetzt ist es soweit
us wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wollen endlich
herausgefunden haben wo genau das
mysteriöse methan aus dem marsboden
erfordert und das ist wirklich kurios
denn die mögliche emissionsquelle könnte
sich in der direkten nähe des mars rover
curiosity
befinden die methan messungen die in der
vergangenheit auf dem roten planeten
stattgefunden haben stellen die fachwelt
vor ein riesiges rätsel der wiederholte
nachweis von methan in der atmosphäre
des planeten bedeutet jedenfalls dass es
eine aktive quelle geben muss und die
liefert immer mehr nach die große frage
die über allem steht woher stammt das
methan ist es möglicherweise
biologischen ursprungs sind es also
mikroorganismen die das methan
produzieren handelte sich also um einen
hinweis auf außerirdisches leben auf dem
roten planeten nicht wenige fachleute
sind mittlerweile fest davon überzeugt
dass es sich um außerirdisches leben
handelt dass das methan sporadisch auf
dem roten planeten produziert doch
bislang war es den fachleuten weltweit
nicht einmal gelungen die quelle des
methans auf dem mars zu orten us
forschende aber wollen genau das jetzt
in zusammenarbeit mit der nasa geschafft
haben und die quelle befindet sich
offensichtlich direkt vor unserer nase
ganz in der nähe des mars rover
curiosity wie und wo genau diese
entdeckung gelang und ob das jetzt der
durchbruch bei unserer suche nach
außerirdischem leben ist das alles und
noch viel mehr gibt es jetzt hier bei
klicks uns einst im future auf unserem
planeten entsteht das gas methan
tatsächlich fast ausschließlich durch
biologische prozesse also durchleben
beispielsweise wenn rinder ihre nahrung
verdauen ausgeschlossen ist allerdings
auch nicht dass das methan auf dem roten
planeten durch geologische prozesse
freigesetzt wird denn das gas kann auch
geochemische entstehen zum beispiel
durch die uv bestrahlung von
gesteinsmaterial bereits sechs mal
konnten die instrumente des nasa posco
city spontan auftretenden
methankonzentration auf dem roten
planeten feststellen im geld kam es
sogar zur richtigen methan ausbrüchen
innerhalb von kurzer zeit stieg der
anteil des gases in der atmosphäre
sprunghaft an nach einer weile sank der
anteil dann wieder die daten die bisher
gesammelt werden konnten zeigen also
dass die methankonzentration auf dem
roten planeten sehr stark und abrupt
wechselt normalerweise liegt sie bei das
blenden 14 das hin zu viel 0 drin ist
also quasi kaum messbar doch im sommer
steigt der wert um 60 prozent an nach
ansicht der fachleute kann dies
keineswegs mit den saisonalen
schwankungen erklärt werden und so ist
dieses rätsel bis heute ungelöst in den
jahren 2013 und 2019 hatte kurjo city
außerdem besonders überraschende
messwerte geliefert und die hatten für
weitere verwirrung gesorgt es waren
überraschend erhöhte methan werte und
das nicht zu knapp das laser
spektrometer hatte vor zwei jahren einen
wert von 21 parts per billion ppb
ermittelt eine konzentration die 20 mal
höher ist als der normalerweise im gate
krater vorherrschen der hintergrund wert
doch so plötzlich wie das methan
aufgetaucht war so plötzlich war es auch
wieder verschwunden die nasa forschenden
hatten curiosity damals einige tage
später eine folge experiment durchführen
lassen und der methan peek war
verschwunden diese messung ergab dann
dass der methan wert wieder auf weniger
als 1 ppb abgesunken war quasi der
hintergrund wert das geld gehört dass
irgendwo muss also eine vorübergehende
ausgasung stattgefunden haben so die
vermutung der fachleute doch wo genau
und was oder wer genau steckt dahinter
befeuert hatte das rätsel zu dem auch
die tatsache dass der exomars trace gas
orbiter tgo der weltraumagentur esa
bislang keinerlei metallvorkommen
nachweisen konnte ganz im gegensatz zu
kohle city das ließ zweifel an den
messungen des mars rovers aufkommen denn
der tgo als schnüffler wurde genau
darauf an jetzt die atmosphäre des mars
genauer ins visier zu nehmen dazu der
nasa wissenschaftler chris webster als
der tgo 2016 liegt an den start kam
hatte ich zu 100 erwartet das op-team
berichten wird dass es überall auf dem
mars eine kleine menge methan gibt ich
war total überrascht dass das
europäische team einen methan bilden
konnte ein riesiges rätsel also über das
wir bereits ausführlich weg sonst kann
es dem user berichtet hatten eine
mögliche erklärung dafür ist dass die
messung von cora city und des teams zu
unterschiedlichen tageszeiten
stattfinden diese these stammt vom
kanadischen planeten wissenschaftler
john nur seine erklärung das ziel-s
instrument von cargo city arbeitet
meistens nachts dann wenn keine anderen
instrumente des rovers aktiv sind der
esa orbiter dagegen arbeitet am tag und
nutzt dabei das sollten sich tatsächlich
konnten aktuelle messungen der nasa
hinweise darauf geben dass john moore
recht behalten könnte fakt ist bisher
bleiben die quellen des methans
verborgen doch um zu klären ob das
methan einen biologischen hintergrund
hat wäre es enorm wichtig eine probe zu
nehmen und diese dann mit der hilfe
eines massenspektrometer zu analysieren
denn das verhältnis der isotope 12c und
14 c könnte tatsächlich aufschluss
darüber geben welchen hintergrund das
gas hat möglicherweise kann genau das
jetzt bald angegangen werden da ein us
forschungsteam in zusammenarbeit mit der
nasa hat tatsächlich eine mögliche
emissionsquelle auf dem roten planeten
aufgespürt haben will wenn die
berechnung sich als richtig
herausstellen könnte sich die mysteriöse
methanquelle quasi vor der nase des mars
rovers befinden zusammen mit forschenden
von der nasa hatten die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vom california institute of technology
die ortsveränderung von commodity
genauer unter die lupe genommen wann
wurden die messungen durchgeführt die
waren die jeweiligen wetterbedingungen
und wie waren die windgeschwindigkeiten
und richtungen zu diesem zeitpunkt all
das waren wichtige detailfragen die die
forschenden mit ihrer analyse
aufgenommen hatten so konnten dann die
wege der methangas partikel bis zu ihrem
möglichen emissionsbanken zurückverfolgt
werden dazu äußert sich das
forschungsziel folgendermaßen
die ergebnisse weisen auf eine aktive
emissions- region im nordwestlichen teil
des kraters im westen und südwesten von
kolja city das sich eine methanquelle
quasi direkt vor köln cities nase
befindet sorgt weltweit für aufregung in
manchen artikeln ist von adyen rück
seien die rede doch klar ist auch selbst
wenn nicht biologische prozesse dahinter
stecken könnten es geologische
aktivitäten seien die mit der existenz
von flüssigem wasser zu tun haben und
auch das ist ja eine wesentliche
voraussetzung für die existenz von leben
mittlerweile wissen wir dass der
geldkarte einen durchmesser von 160
kilometern hat entstanden ist dieser
wohl durch einen meteoriteneinschlag vor
3,5 milliarden jahren dieser hatte einst
dafür gesorgt dass sich das klima auf
dem roten planeten veränderte die flüsse
und seen in einem einst feucht warmen
klima verwandelten sich in eine karge
wüstenlandschaft dazu der us
wissenschaftler william rappen im geld
krater ist der wandel des mars auf
einzigartige weise konserviert somit ist
jetzt also klar wie der rote planet vor
etwa 3,5 milliarden jahren ausgesehen
hat wasser war demnach ein zentrales
element auf dem planeten hat sich also
in dieser zeit leben auf dem roten
planeten entwickelt dass möglicherweise
sogar noch heute existiert die fachleute
selbst betonen aber dass diese
ergebnisse sind noch mit vorsicht zu
genießen sind die studie wartet noch auf
ihr peer review dabei beleuchten
unabhängige wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler studien sehr genau diese
dann in fachzeitschriften wie es einst
oder nature beispielsweise publiziert
werden doch einiges spricht nach ansicht
des forschungsteams dafür dass curiosity
offensichtlich durch zufall in der nähe
einer aktiven methanquelle verweilt
möglicherweise sogar nur ein paar
kilometer von ihm entfernt im geldkarte
hier ist er bereits seit neun jahren
unterwegs hauptsächlich auf der suche
nach spuren von leben pro stunde kann
curiosity 30 meter zurücklegen mit der
hilfe seiner 17 kameras an bord um 10
forschungsinstrumenten ist der perfekt
ausgestattet um wichtige daten zusammen
diese werden dann an die erde gefunkt
und ermöglichen des forschungsteams
rückschlüsse auf die geschichte und
bewohnbarkeit des roten planeten zu
ziehen die studie jedenfalls weg große
hoffnung leben auf dem mars curiosity
hat methan rätsel löst hier geht es um
die ecke das ist rund um die vermutung
von john moore die ja bestätigt wurden
also anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
ist kostenlos geht da und in jedem
button unter dem video und ansonsten bis
dann